could an entire film be brought down by
a single line from boring Batman to
cringy bond and even a chatty dinosaur
when it comes to movies there's no such
thing as Perfection Johnny Lawrence the
real hero of the karate kid has his fill
of Daniel Larusso in the movie this new
kid from out of town moves in on his
girl Ali Mills and does quite the mouth
on him too like any good 80s sports
flick their conflict culminates in a
karate bout where Daniel defeats Johnny
with an illegal crane kick before Daniel
receives his trophy Johnny grabs it but
instead of clogging the Russo over the
head with the thing Johnny hands it over
and says
really these two have had beef
throughout the entire film Daniel kicked
him in the face with an illegal move and
Johnny suddenly wants to be friends has
anyone checked Johnny for a concussion
also this creates something of a plot
hole because Cobra Kai shows how Johnny
saw Harbor's resentment towards Daniel
and he definitely doesn't think he's all
right while James Bond's on-screen
Adventures have brought action-packed
adrenaline rushes to generations of fans
the films have also featured
questionable and often sexist dialogue
007 has a dishonor of being a cringe
Lord at the best of times however he
takes the proverb your cake in 1981's
for your eyes only after teenage figure
skater baby doll tries to seduce him by
laying naked in his bed Roger Moore's
Bond turns down her advances due to her
age saying you get your clothes on
I'll buy you an ice cream go buy an ice
cream because she's an ice skater and
she's young you get it yeah not many did
another reason why some of the Bond
films have an eggs while in retrospect
in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
Harry visits a zoo with the dursleys and
has a chat with the boa constrictor
behind the glass saying I've never
talked to a snake before
do you
oh wait did you talk to people often
Harry do you think this snake would be
locked up in a zoo if I had the chance
to State its case to someone this poor
creature would probably be chatty but
chassis if anyone would listen
explaining how it dreams of slithering
around Wide Open Spaces capturing its
own food and swallowing it whole
fortunately the snake manages to escape
and even thanks Harry for his
inadvertent help Blake Lively's Nancy
Adams goes through it and Joe May
Colette Sarah's the shallows all she
wants to do is hit the waves until she
spots a whale carcass and a great white
shark sinks its teeth into her leg to
escape Jaws as younger cousin Lively
climbs on top of the whale carcass
hoping someone will see her her leash is
out of the way of the shark right wrong
all of a sudden the shark starts to pull
the whale carcass and move her along the
water instead of screaming bloody murder
Lively asked the shark where are you
taking me
no one's sure she actually expects the
shark to reply or to drop a pin to the
coordinates on Google Maps maybe she's
thinking out loud but no forget it
moving on Robert Rodriguez is Once Upon
a Time in Mexico isn't afraid to get
ridiculous the 2003 film is bursting at
the scene to the music dialogue and
outrageous logic defying action
sequences however there's one line early
on in the film that stands out for all
the wrong reasons as agent Sans played
by Johnny Depp walks into the restaurant
to meet El Mariachi played by Antonio
Banderas Danny Trejo as Kukui airs is
concerned about the meeting without
missing a beat a straight face Sans
turns to Kukui and says are you a
Mexican
or a mexicant a decade earlier in a time
when people spoke about Nintendo and
Nintendo don't the Limelight might have
been pure gold but it's awful in this
context and not even Johnny Depp can
save it as entertaining as MCU movies
are they also feature some atrocious eye
rolling dialogue consider Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness while the
movie features decent one-liners and
genuine moments of levity there's a
single line that turns Dr Strange into a
Bonafide doofus now remember he is a
former sorcerer Supreme someone who
knows about the Multiverse magic and
probably Mephisto too yet when Baron
mordo tells him the Illuminati will see
him his replay is the illumawadi
seriously how does Doctor Strange not
know about the Illuminati I mean he
knows all about the Fantastic Four and
they hadn't even debuted in the MCU but
he has no clue about a world famous
so-called secret society not buying it
there has long been a debate if there
was space for Jack Dawson on Rose to a
bouqueta's rafts in Titanic however the
real question should be why didn't she
even try after Jack freezes to death and
Rose realizes he's gone she begs him to
come back to her holding his hand she
says I'll never let go I promise
[Music]
foreign
promptly lets go of him while her words
are a metaphor for her feelings and how
he will always have a place in her heart
like the Celine Dion song says it's
actually pretty funny how she does the
one thing she promised she would never
do in a heartbeat and inevitably it
takes a lot of the emotional punch out
of the scene
to be fair Jack reads she was never
going to win an Oscar for its screenplay
or contributions to cinematic
immortality the film is all about
watching Tom Cruise's Reacher kick the
snot out of people but there's a moment
when Jack Reacher tries to recreate the
infamous phone scene from Taken and it's
a lesson in why filmmaking needs to be
more about showing than telling Richard
picks up the phone and dials Jay
Courtney's Charlie then a visibly
seething Reacher says
I am not a hero I'm a Drifter with
nothing to lose yeah doesn't that last
part sound like the tagline for the DVD
cover who tells someone they're a
drifter in the first place it's just
plain weird
Jurassic Park 3 gets an unnecessarily
bad rap while it might not have the same
lightning in a puzzled effect of the
first film or the dialed up Terror of
the lost world it's still that dinosaurs
chasing humans and is therefore
excellent entertainment unfortunately
most people remember Jurassic Park 3 for
the single moment when it jumps the
shark or Velociraptor of course Dr Alan
Graham would have Trauma from his first
trip to Jurassic Park after nearly being
eaten alive several times as he falls
asleep on the plane ride back there he
dreams that the pilot disappears as the
terror engulfs him he looks to his side
where Velociraptor stares back at him
the Raptor opens its mouth and says
foreign
snaps out of his days and realizes
someone else is calling him what is
clear director Joe Johnston was going
for comedic effect here it completely
undercuts the threat of the Raptor from
here on out how do you top the talking
Raptor regardless of Leonardo DiCaprio's
highly inaccurate Zimbabwean accent and
Edward zweck's Blood Diamond the 2006
film is fondly remembered for its
intense action and phenomenal
performances however there's one
cringe-worthy line in the film that
screenwriter Charles Levitt should never
have committed to Prince When DiCaprio's
dannyacha meets Jennifer Connelly's
Maddie Bowen at the bar they talk about
the state of the world and their place
in it Maddie asked Dany if he's a
Smuggler which he is and he responds
Americans bling bling but out here it's
bling bang while it's intended to be
clever wordplay no one in Africa speaks
that way besides it's cheesy bling bang
it sounds like a new Spicy corn chip
flavor don't Rattle and Powers have
never mastered the art of witty banter
instead they're more than happy to put
the pedal to the metal and rejoice in
being family and all the nonsense it
brings with her while 2001s are fast and
the furious isn't exactly a
Shakespearean sonnet to begin with there
is one extremely puzzling line spoken by
Dom's sister Mia describing her brother
he's like gravity
everything just gets pulled to him
even you at first listen it sounds like
a deep and thoughtful metaphor about the
way her brother attracts people but it's
technically nonsense yes gravity pulls
everything toward the center so it
follows that according to Mia Siri Dom
drags people to the ground not to him
again this isn't entirely wrong in the
grand context of the story but Mia's
definition of gravity has a fundamental
flaw in terms of basic logic The Dark
Knight trilogy showcases some fantastic
writing and iconic one-liners that said
The Dark Knight Rises is often
considered the weakest entry in the
series and for good reason Bane is all
the best dialogue in the film or
Batman's appears to be an afterthought
nowhere is this more evident than in the
scene with a dark knight recovered from
his broken back returns to Gotham City
to face off against Bane Bane asked him
if he came back to perish for the city
and Batman replies
I came back to stop you
wow that's so boring does a dark knight
need to speak here you could have just
slugged Bane in this silly mask and let
his fist to the talking
Star Wars fans know the conclusion of
the Skywalker Saga was riddled with
Studio problems and numerous changes
after the fan outcrying responds to The
Last Jedi lucasfilm chose for peace of
fan base rather than stir up more
controversy with its original plan it's
no surprise then that Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker suffers as it tries to
wreck on the previous film and close the
trilogy for the most part a movie asks
the viewer to Simply go with it however
one of its worst lines clearly
illustrates the overall chaos behind the
scenes after two films where there was
no inkling that Palpatine was back the
evil emperor appears in the rise of
Skywalker with a paper-thin explanation
but nothing is quite as bad as when Poe
Dameron tells the others
somehow Palpatine returned
hey no one can fault his honesty here
pose seems to be in the same boat as the
audience and probably the filmmakers too
since no one understands how or why this
happened Just Go With It fans know to
expect The Eccentric from a Paul
verhoven film if he isn't having RoboCop
shoot a criminal in the nether regions
he'll have Arnold Schwarzenegger's eyes
bulging out of their ice sockets in
Total Recall though it isn't
Schwarzenegger who gets the most bizarre
moments in the movie but the villain
Villas cohagen played by Ronnie Cox in a
typical third act scene Villas points
are going to Schwarzenegger's hero and
monologues away about his master plan
saying in 30 seconds you'll be dead then
I'll blow this place up and be home in
time for cornflakes wait what as of all
the things of bad guys looking forward
to doing after he succeeds it's eating
corn flakes now look a villain needs to
eat but one would expect him to be
excited for caviar or shrimp a big old
steak or even mac and cheese but Corn
Flakes man really is a monster
oh Twilight is a gift that keeps on
giving even star Robert Pattinson
couldn't believe the books were actually
published in a cruel twist of fate he
ended up spouting more than a few
winners during his time in the franchise
one gem that inevitably elicits a
chuckle is you better hold on tight
spider monkey however there's another
even more Awkward comedy moment after
Edward Cullen exposes a sparkly secret
to Bella Swan she tells him how
beautiful he is disgusted Edward replies
beautiful
skin of the killer Bill
okay yes that's virtually correct but
come on it's amazing button someone's
able to keep a straight face long enough
to get the words out even Kristen
Stewart must have been in stitches when
he said here
[Music]
foreign